you're so you're telling me on air right
now it's odell beckham's fault
that the giants have absolutely i'm
telling you that i've been telling you
that for five years this super bowl down
i don't see anything less than that you
got a wide receiver that is always hurt
with a big mouth i just think that cat's
ruined him i think his head got big man
you're a [ __ ] in unison the entire bar
started chan no b.j the excitement is
real gentlemen the excitement is real
otto beckham jr out of cleveland in new
york plenty of grievances mainly from
new york whether it's
upset that he's gone or defending the
decision by being upset at him though
chris it still feels like the browns got
the better of this one but that's a good
way to tee up our weekly segment airing
of grievances i will give you the first
opportunity to complain about anything
you would like to complain i'm gonna
complain about just that little mashup
of stuff right off the bat here i gotta
just like i mean some of that's just
ridiculous oh they haven't won because
of odell beckham jr no the stats and the
facts are the exact opposite of that so
they can bullcrap all they want because
maybe some of these radio people don't
like the way a new era wide receiver
acts but the stats show the giants win a
lot more when odell plays and eli
manning is a lot better when odell plays
and when odell doesn't play he lives in
blake bortlesville because that's where
his stats are in this whole thing so
that's crazy and some of those people on
there act worse than antonio brown and
odell beckham jr and they're radio hosts
but yet they don't like when they're
caught the football player acts like
that and that drives me crazy it's so
hypocritical uh so one of them's a very
big mouth who says things that aren't
true all the time and has has caused a
lot of problems at his office and i
would say you're you're worse than odell
beckham jr so don't be so critical of
o'dell because you're more like antonio
brown there's my first grievance how do
you like that who are you talking about
wait i'm just i'm my princess
yeah okay that's what i'm talking about
follow me okay
i was i was being sarcastic
no i listen to you sometimes all right i
i like that one here's mine and this
one's been bothering me and i talked
about it earlier
on the radio show before we joined nbcsn
for the simulcast the
the this this
tampering window negotiating period
whatever they want to call it they set
it up because tampering was rampant and
once the league year began so many of
these deals were done so quickly it was
obvious that negotiations were happening
before
the time for permissible negotiations
had come so they created a window where
you can do it so it's like you know what
we know everybody's breaking the rules
so let's change the rule to give them a
window where they can break the war
without breaking the rule but now the
problem is they're still breaking the
rule and it's becoming obvious because
these deals are all being leaked and
reported
minutes in the case of trent brown hours
in the case of many others after the
negotiating window opens so the
tampering is still happening and here's
what the nfl has created in in an effort
to avoid criticism of the fact that
everyone is tampering they've created
this window that results in this and and
this is the best metaphor i can come up
with
it's like getting an invitation to a
party that starts on saturday night
ready to go on saturday night and
finding out the party started two days
earlier and the the the
people invited to the party are the
audience that the nfl is catering to
that we are catering to everybody thinks
that wednesday's the day and if you're
not paying close attention on monday and
tuesday come wednesday your party's over
right and you're fine and basically what
you're doing is you're you're thinking
wednesday's the day that free agency
starts and then you start hearing these
ribs and drabs of deals that are getting
done it's like i guess the party already
started i better get there and and the
nfl needs to get rid of this just start
the process right whether it's noon on
monday or four on wednesday start the
process there's an element of
showmanship that the nfl needs to
embrace here you gather your audience
and you hold your audience and it needs
to feel like a big deal they have taken
what used to feel like a big deal and
they have deluded it and that is a huge
mistake get rid of the tampering period
start the engines start the race and who
cares if it's obvious there was
tampering it's still obvious there's
tampering and they never do anything
about it so why are you worried about it
yeah and and to what you're saying
because i agree with you 100
i mean it's diluted and yet it's still
awesome and still getting a ton of
coverage so imagine how much more
coverage it would get if it was just a
little more well thought out and planned
i still think and i don't know where you
think about this mike i really think the
new league year should start when we go
to indianapolis or the nfl combine i
disagree i disagree here's why tell me
when i'll tell you why and you've said
that a few times this week and it dawned
on me today right the nfl tries to
create in the offseason three major tent
poles scouting combine free agency and
the draft and if you allow the
negotiating window to open at the
scouting combine it does anyway but if
you allow it to open then what's going
to happen five minutes later trent
brown's got to deal with the raiders so
you don't want to dilute the combine by
jamming it together with free agency
free agency needs to stand alone and it
needs to start at the same moment you
can't have this soft launch to free
agency just launch the damn thing if
you're trying to guess here's the thing
in the off season the nfl can't sell
anything other than interest and you
maximize interest by having that one day
when the ball drops at the start of the
new league year it was a joke yesterday
when four o'clock came oh yeah the new
league year is here we already know
everything is going to happen why do we
even care that's a mistake by the nfl
and it's a mistake they need to
acknowledge and fix yeah i'm sorry yeah
no you're right you're right and i'll
say even my take i think with the
combine thing you made perfect sense
there i think i agree with you let the
combine live as itself and yeah start
free agency after that totally makes
sense so i'm with you you proved me
wrong there i do wish that the combine
we could talk about joe flacco trades
and things like that where the nfl would
change that rule when we know he's being
traded it's out there it's public
knowledge but we still got to act like
the teams can't talk about it the teams
don't want to talk about it because it's
against rules that drives me crazy so uh
or or let me say this chris if you're if
you're not going to let the trades
become official
then force the teams to keep their mouth
shut about it until the start of free
agency now because i remember there was
a there was a starter free agency a few
years ago where three trades happened
bang bang bang it was jimmy graham to
the seahawks it was sam bradford for
nick foles and there was one other trade
that i keep forgetting but it was like
whoa and just think just think if we
didn't know
that
joe flacco was getting traded to the
ravens right that antonio brown was
getting traded to the raiders that odell
beckham just think of all that stuff hit
at the same time what a day it would
have been yeah no you're right it would
have been amazing i mean i i don't even
know if they all would have got the
attention they deserved because it would
have been like an overflow of we
wouldn't had enough time in a two-hour
show here to talk about it all but yes
it would be amazing it would be so much
attention uh and just you know his
social news everything would be all over
it so i'm with you there okay i'm gonna
move on to my next grievance my next
grievance has a little bit to do with
kylo murray and it has a little bit more
to do with what i see on tv in the
scouting world and all that kind of
stuff this is what's driving me crazy
about it okay kyler murray when i look
at a lot of people uh you know across
the field and i'm not trying to take a
shot at anyone i'm just trying to make
logic of this i guess is when i look at
it and everyone has their big board
right top 50 players this is how i rank
them kyla murray is like not in the top
10 of any of these and i just want to go
why i don't understand that we're still
in this old world thinking you know how
are you going to tell me you know people
like last year on the big board baker
mayfield and sam darnold were in the top
five in the top two and the top three of
everybody's big board but yet the guy
coming out the next year who's faster
and has a stronger arm than sam darnold
and it's very close between him and
baker mayfield
and he's maybe the best playmaker we've
seen at the position in a while coming
out of college football how is he 13 i
just don't understand that and
especially when he's talked about being
the number one pick in the draft and
everybody that watches them goes oh my
gosh this guy's amazing he's better than
i thought he's the number one pick in
the draft he's pretty phenomenal and
then we talk about the value of the
quarterback position because when i turn
on the tv it's always oh you know the
quarterback has a little extra value so
the guy who's the like one of the
freakier quarterbacks we've seen come
out in the draft who won the heisman
plays the position the right way makes
great decisions is an on point bullseye
thrower is the best running guy i've
seen come out of college since michael
vick
but yet he we're not gonna put him on
the big board in the top two or top
three that just makes no sense to me
sometimes when i read the scouting
reports and then see the rankings i go
wait your scouting report sometimes
reads like the guy's a top two or three
pick but yet you ranked them at 14 or 15
for some reason why because of 510 so
that's what i'm pushing back against
that it just drives me crazy it's one of
those things i look at
yeah and no matter how many quarterbacks
are successful south of six foot this is
not going away and maybe it's not going
to go away until that generation of
scouts naturally cycles out of the
business who knows but and
look peop and here's the thing and
here's the
the only way that i can explain this is
there is so much cya that goes on in
scouting yep you you want to you know
and and you also you want to be able to
say i said hey i was the one who said
you know there's this issue here because
then if the guy's a bust you're right
yeah right so yeah there's a lot in
there's a lot of naysayers who are who
who kind of lurk in the weeds but
they're on record
and then when they if they draft the guy
in the guy's a bus they can say they
were right and there's a lot of that
gamesmanship that goes on as well all
right uh
the le'veon bell contract i talked about
this earlier on the radio side too this
really bothers me the people who just
refuse to understand
why he didn't play last year
and why playing and getting 14 and a
half million would have risked what he
got from the jets right adida king ball
of nfl media reported 28 million fully
guaranteed i'm anxious to see the full
contract but if it's 28 million fully
guaranteed it's signing which is
something the steelers were not going to
give him that's the problem the steelers
do not structure their contracts to put
that much fully guaranteed money into a
deal the only way he was getting it was
get to the open market so he went
without the 14 and a half million as a
way to preserve the ability to get the
28. if you take the 14 and a half and
you suffer a torn achilles tendon a torn
acl a broken leg whatever now it didn't
hurt quinn alexander but bell's
perspective is a running back you got to
think about you suffer an injury and you
don't get your big payday you give up
the medium payday to preserve the
life-changing multi-generational payday
and it's that simple right but but but
the people who didn't like the fact it
offends the sensibilities that did all
they sat out a year oh you don't do that
how dare you sit out here oh but you
must have made a mistake because they
don't want other people to sit out a
year and they try to double down
and and bolster their argument that he
shouldn't have sat out by making what i
think is a false argument and not
understanding and appreciating the
detail here the nuance here of what he
was sitting out for exactly right no i
know it's just uh it's lack of knowledge
on the whole situation the full scope of
everything that goes involved in this
and yeah to to people the you know the
common fan everybody that's watching
you're gonna look at it and go uh he
didn't sign for as much money as i
thought he would and hey same here i did
i thought he would get a bigger total
number all together either way but
either way what you're hearing is you
know the number we're hearing at this
point right is 28 million right fully
guaranteed at signing 35 35 million for
injury so therefore right off the bat it
makes a lot more sense he
he didn't want to risk getting hurt last
year and never seen that big payday so
i'm with you my good one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports